what's going on guys so are you ever
watching one of your favorite movies and
you see an actor and you're all like
wait they are in that that's what we're
talking about today but forgotten early
work of well-known actors in well-known
movies we're very excited to compile
these for you and we're calling it wait
they were in that that's all we could
come up with our first one comes to us
from the 1977 Best Picture winner Woody
Allen's Annie Hall before it was
everyone's favorite chaos theorists Jeff
Goldblum was found right here at the
super weird 70s party yeah I I forgot my
mantra luckily he found his mantra which
turned out to be his super weird laugh
from Jurassic Park Wow our next actor
finished the Kessel run in under 12
parsecs kick Gary Oldman off his plane
and of course fell in love with
animation six days seven nights we all
saw that right
but did you know that Harrison Ford was
in Apocalypse Now pick up Colonel
Kurtz's path at new manga follow it
learn what you can along the way when
you find the kernel infiltrate his team
by mmm whatever means available some
people might call that great acting why
he just couldn't remember his lines I
mean that's what I do when I'm stalling
let's turn now to Steven Spielberg's
acclaimed war movie Saving Private Ryan
Tom Hanks spent an entire film searching
until he found Matt Damon but audiences
found a lot of other people in this
movie I bet you didn't remember that one
of his main team members was Vin Diesel
every time you salute the captain you
make him a target for the Germans so do
us a favor don't do it especially when
I'm standing next to the Capetian or
that the wrong Private Ryan turned out
to be Nathan Fillion you're James right
yeah James Francis Ryan
my gym shredder Brian Minnesota but the
biggest find in this acclaimed war drama
Brian frickin Cranston as an army man
this wounded Omaha Beach Daniel Ryan hey
guys can we please talk Zoe Saldana she
is excellent at playing gorgeous aliens
that make me feel kind of weird for
thinking they're hot
like materi and gomorrah but she was
also in Pirates of the Caribbean
annamaria unfortunately they never
brought her back for any of sequels you
know who cares about the black pearl
where's the black girl too far not
nothing wrong enough this next one may
come as no surprise because he's been in
like half of all movies ever but it's
easy to forget that Samuel Jackson was
in Martin Scorsese's Goodfellas yeah you
always late you were late for your own
funeral that was Samuel Jackson's most
unexpected death until he was eaten by
that shark in deep blue sea let's see
that just because we're gonna feel
when you think about the movie
collateral you think Jamie Foxx Tom
Cruise Michael Mann you know you don't
think about rapper turned actor Ice Cube
which is good because he is not in
collateral but you know who is Jason
Statham
you okay yeah I'm fun night don't worry
about it I'm thinking a collateral crank
crossover I've already written the
script
I call it crank lateral Michael man call
me anybody please call me you know back
to the future - as the hit sequel that
as it turns out completely lied to us
about the future everyone remembers the
stars - Michael J Fox Christopher Lloyd
and Elijah Wood yep use your hands
that's like a baby's toy but Michael J
Fox wasn't the only star to share the
screen with young Elijah Wood Black
Widow herself Scarlett Johansson made
her screen debut in the 1994 critically
we're a huge film North so great having
you here short they've always wanted a
brother to throw - yeah now I've - big
brother so Calgary here's another major
star making his first appearance in a
popular comedy southpaw is a Dylan home
even though he didn't get a chance to
rope any steers he did get to act
opposite Billy Crystal in 1991's
oscar-winning city slickers my dad's
name Mitch and he's he's a submarine
commander this is Annie
he works for WBO on radio the new movie
American ultra just hit theaters and I
hear it's like Jason Bourne and
pineapple Express had a baby both of its
stars Kristen Stewart and Jesse
Eisenberg have unusual unexpected stuff
in their careers but Jesse Eisenberg's
is really odd he was in this dr. pepper
commercial which I know it's a
commercial not a movie what we're
talking about here but let's watch it
kind of like the deep blue sea thing
just because your little way is gonna
have to come right to the other world
don't be on the way wrong it's all right
sorry about that step aside put naked
American ultras Kristen Stewart's
probably best known as Bella from
Twilight but long before her turn as
vampire Android's lover she worked for
an even colder more mysterious man
director David Fincher as Jodie Foster's
daughter and the film panic won't get
out of my house one of the two guys
menacing Kristen Stewart by the way was
a corn road jared leto
who won an Oscar alongside co-star
Matthew McConaughey for Dallas buyers
pay McConaughey has many distinguished
worlds to his credit but his most
magical role has to be as a member of
the California Angels and the tiny
Joseph gordon-levitt vehicle angels in
the outfit fell weightless like somebody
had me by the arms kid how'd I do that
not only did Matthew McConaughey get to
star in a beloved children's film but he
was also able to keep his shirtless on
film streak alive another Best Actor
winner is the late great Philip Seymour
Hoffman he left behind a legacy of
fantastic performances ranging from
arthouse films like Capote to his turn
as dusty a tornado chasing wild man in
1996 is twister
this sucks own
it's the point basically at which the
twister sucks you up next up we have two
Magneto's Michael Fassbender and Sir Ian
McKellen
both of them have Oscar nominations and
critical acclaim to their name but they
also played minor roles in big-budget
action movies fast benders film debut
was as Stelios one of Gerard Butler's AB
tastic soldiers and Zack Snyder's 300
our arrows will blot out the Sun then we
will fight in the shade sir in showed a
little more modesty playing the road
death and Arnold Schwarzenegger Last
Action Hero
he's not on any of my lists though you
are Daniel with all due respect to
certain McKellen that performance still
ranks as the second best portrayal of
death on screen behind of course villain
Ted's bogus journey you have sank my
battleship speaking of death let's wrap
things up with Charles Bronson's 1974
hit death wish while the film may be
best known for launching four brutally
violent sequels it also launched two
careers who fractures making her
on-screen debut the first an uncredited
Denzel Washington yep he gets blown away
in an alley in a second it's him again
Jeff Goldblum who plays a character
credited as reek number one launching an
entire career of typecasting
look at that lovely little Jeff Goldblum
bookends that was a nice time what actor
was in a movie that you were watching
and you were like wait they were in that
let us know in the comment section below
best answer we're gonna send you a
Screen Gems teacher I want to thank you
for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter bye bye
what planet was destroyed by the Death
Star in Star Wars a new hope Alderaan
number four name four of the seven
actors to play James Bond in a film
George Lazenby Sean Connery Roger Lord
Pierce Brosnan